live local now a deadly crime spree on
new year's eve
8 news now bringing you exclusive video
showing what witnesses say is a shooting
suspect being taken into police custody
thanks for joining us here at 11 o'clock
i'm denise valdez and i'm brian loftis
it was friday night two people shot and
killed as two men stopped at various
properties targeting people in parking
garages so that crime spree started
about 1 30 friday night at the fashion
show mall 66 year old clarice yamaguchi
from hawaii was killed here and then a
few hours later metro officers reported
an attempted robbery in the parking
garage at the sahara hotel a gunshot was
fired but no one was hurt then about an
hour later a man was shot and killed at
the palace station garage and not long
after that two men were arrested on the
strip all in connection to this crime
spree victoria saha spoke to a witness
tonight and is back where this all
started for a story you'll only see on 8
news now
good evening brian and denise the
suspect shorted their crime spree right
behind me here at the fashion show mall
where they allegedly shot and killed
their first victim it would be hours
until they were arrested
this is exclusive video eight news now
obtained of 20-year-old jordan ruby
being walked away in handcuffs at the
food court inside of bali's hotel ruby
along with 20 year old jasoni carter are
accused in the new year's eve crime
spree a local makeup artist who
witnessed the arrest shared this video
explaining the moments before police
swarmed in they both had trays in their
hand and it was like a brief second that
i looked at them both together
and i was like oh that's you know
they're probably just traveling or
whatever she doesn't want to be
identified in fear of retaliation she
says soon after the suspects got their
food they separated i know that vegas
has its crazy moments but to have it
that close to me like you know carter
and ruby were arrested around 7 30
friday evening nearly six hours after
the first incident police have connected
them to a police source close to 8 news
now confirms the suspected car was
located at the valley's property and
both suspects were arrested inside they
just looked like they were hanging out
like when they were grabbing their food
they didn't look like they just
shot someone and killed them
back out here live both carter and ruby
are expected to be in court tomorrow
morning on open murder charges we will
have a crew inside the courtroom and
we'll bring you the latest details
reporting live tonight by the fashion
show mall victoria saha live local now
and